You
Oh my god, I finally done it
Okay, should I start the game does anyone want do you want more strokes? Do you want more? I would love more
Yeah, collision will be funny
We can hit each other we hit each other's balls. Oh my god
Did you guys customize your balls? No, no, how do you do that? How do I customize my balls? I can customize my balls
Yeah, that's all the main screen. You guys didn't customize your balls
Hope let's sit. Oh my gosh. I can customize my ball. Give me a second. What's the name is the
options. I thought you said
I
Got I have a flaming hot ball
Okay, now my ball has hearts
There's one with axis in me
Oh
Everyone's so excited to have their own custom ball
All right, let me know you're done customizing your balls
Then you should like radio
Oh
My ready I can't tell if I'm ready or if I'm not ready it turns
I don't know green or yellow is ready. I'm ready to wake up green green is ready. Oh, okay
I'm ready
Yeah
Well, oh not every player is ready not every player is ready
How do we play how do I play?
Wait
How do I do this? Hello?
This is so weird
I'm so close
Wait, I don't know how to do it either. How do you game? You have to
Click
Hershey's is so cute you got to pull it back early pop
Ezra will say thank you once the collabs over. Um, but thank you everyone who's supporting this
Ignore me
No way
Fuck get me off the fucking thing
Oh
I'm still struggling to figure out how to play right now
You got this little sis. Yeah
It is so much better. No, not the double boogie
The boogie of course a double boogie
I got boogie. Oh shit as boogie is. Where's the hole?
I'm scared
Let's go
Oh
I thought I was gonna be the only one that didn't get it and I was gonna cry
Hi, thank you
I'm trying to learn how to do this is hard. Okay
I am terrible at this. Please. I'm gonna thank god. Triple bogey. That's fine. I can work
out this mercy. We didn't play a practice room to be honest. We're just going to seven
strokes for different folks. Thank you, Mr. Anonymous. Thank you, Mr. Anonymous. Oh,
frick. Hold on. Oh, frick. I'm truly dark in this one. I see. Why are you on my back side
right now? I see. I do what I want. I can't see. I'll get the action show. Am I just dead?
Golf. Golf. Golf. Golf. Golf. Golf. Golf. I'm so mad. Oh, my God. All right. Here we go.
We got to do where the fuck I am. Come on. Come on. Where the fuck I am. Okay, hold on.
Fuck this shit. Me and Mercy are struggling over here. I can tell. I'm fine. I'm not the one
struggling in the game for the rest of my life. I'll thank you. Shut up. Talks and golf. You know what?
Me and Mercy, we're fine on the bottom. We'll lift everybody up, you know? I don't want to be on the bottom. I want to be on top. Where's the hole?
Oh, fuck. What? You can come off the ground. Can I jump? Is jumping the same? I don't know. You can come off this map. Okay, right.
Enough. That's three strokes. I keep trolling. I'm trolling. Stop trolling. Come on. Okay. Now we start. Damn. Am I going to roll over?
What?
Oh, my God. I'm going to Kermit.
Guys, guys. What the hell is this?
I'm throwing. I'm going to throw. I'm going to throw so freaking hard.
No, no, no, no, no. I'm going to cry. Where am I? Hello? Oh, what the fuck am I supposed to say? No, I killed Aisy. I killed Aisy.
I'm creeping. I'm on the edge of glory.
Fuck this. I'm not going to live in the old me. Who the fuck am I doing? Who the fuck am I doing?
Who the fuck am I doing?
Of course.
Strati has salt.
I did it.
It's not a maximum amount. There has to be a maximum amount. It's 12 strokes.
Well, it can't be because I've managed to win this little game.
I thought it was 12. I guess it's not.
Shortened behavior. Shortened behavior.
Oh, almost holding one.
That was a moment. I needed to even the playing field.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I swore.
How dare you swear?
I can't believe you, Mercy. How could you swear? It's so fucking stupid.
I got the trick shot.
I'm so sorry. I said such bad words. I will remember to fuck myself.
You're going up. You're going up.
Yourself? I can't believe you're going up yourself.
Are you winning?
What the fuck is the salt thing?
It's me. I put salt on myself.
Oh my god.
What the heck?
Strati got one.
I'm Scottish. Didn't you know golf started in Scotland to have like a racial passive to this?
I'm not even kidding.
Stop, stop, stop.
Please, please, please.
We have thrown in that 17.
No, I see. I see it's on the bottom.
I see his bottom and only one made up for all your 12 strokes.
What was that?
What was our math?
That was me having mental breakdown.
Let's go.
Strati, get out of my face. Strati, don't fuck me up.
I was doing so good. What the fuck?
Are you reaching over golf right now?
Wow.
I always fucking suck at games.
Give me a second.
I got a spammer in chat.
What are they saying?
I'm going to far on them.
Shibin on them.
Shibin and Fartin so hard.
You know them hard.
I'm tired because I block that motherfucker.
Motherfucker.
Thank you.
What?
That was like a pro strat. Hold on.
What the hell?
This shit.
Dammit.
Where is the hole?
It's like through the yellow tunnel.
How am I going to jump through that?
I keep on getting the...
Okay.
So mad.
That was going to be A plus plus.
Why do I have to be behind whatever the fuck this is?
What does bogey mean?
Stop.
Bogey is free.
I'm being hit.
I'm going to start choosing violence.
And I'm going to start targeting others.
Don't sabotage us.
Wait, they're moving?
The goal is moving.
Here we go.
What the hell?
We got time, man.
We need to pick the easy peasy levels.
What is this?
But it makes it harder.
Where am I?
Are we supposed...
There's no way we're supposed to just eat ourselves.
Let's do a little bit of this.
Let's do a little bit of that.
And then a little bit of this.
Sorry.
No, never mind.
How am I supposed to fucking do it?
Please.
Please, I'm begging.
Let me come a little bit closer.
Shit.
Oh shit, I did it before.
I got this.
I don't get all this.
Bad timing. It's okay.
Okay, we're still here.
Quick time of it.
Oh, thank you so much.
I'm sorry.
Thank you very much.
I'm so close.
Oh wait, that actually almost helped me.
Where am I?
Emmy, go!
Emmy, I'll let you go first.
What the fuck was that?
I'm sorry!
What the hell was that, Emmy?
I can't!
Wait, did anyone get in the hurry?
Damn.
I killed myself.
I'm throwing myself on the train tracks for real.
I'm about to end it all.
Jesus.
That was so hard.
Azura did it?
I did it!
Okay, I'm going to come a little bit closer.
Yes!
I don't think this is happening.
No, wait, how did I not get in the hole?
You did get it, Mercy.
You got it, Mercy.
I only got it.
I only got 25.
Congratulations!
Thank you!
Thank you for the 25, Mr. Anonymous.
Why did I get penalized 17?
No one else called penalized 17?
Why do you say it like that?
Penalized?
I got ethic hide.
Penalized.
Where's the thing?
Over there.
Wait, how do you...
How do you say penis?
How do you spell penalized?
P-E-N-I
P...
P-E-N-A
You're doing it too strong.
I don't know how to spell.
Listen to me.
Where is the gun?
In the hole.
The fucking train!
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Wait, any of these is the goal?
I wish I could...
I've never played this game before.
Hey, Estrani, how do you say pen?
Pen.
I'm literally gonna cover...
Penalized.
Please feel the love of the holy goddess Azuro.
That was fucking hard.
Oh, god.
Which one is the hole?
Are they all the holes?
Hole.
My hole.
Oh, I thought I was a crab.
How am I supposed to...
Bunk.
I'm glad I'm not the one...
I'm still at the fucking start.
I'm still at the start too.
I have to relax.
Okay, I did it.
I made it.
Alright, let's go.
Now I just realized I forgot to turn off this.
What?
What are you doing?
What have you done?
That's nothing, so they didn't do anything.
Did you have your background music on?
No!
Oh, mine is. I saw my background music on.
Now where?
Okay, alright.
Where is it?
Bunk.
It's the same place as before.
I'm going this way.
I'm following Emmy.
Rather gently that time.
Do apologize.
Shit.
Alright.
I'm on X games.
So is Emmy.
No!
Stay, stay, stay.
That was so funny to see.
Son of a...
Double bogey.
Someone literally goes to my stream.
I switched streams just to say,
it's Pen Owl Lies.
Okay, dude.
Pen Owl Lies.
Queen Owl Lies.
What happened?
What are you doing?
Fuck!
I see Frozen.
No, I killed Icy.
No, you killed Icy.
In what?
Glitching for me.
Let's go home.
What the fuck?
What is this?
You guys suck at gosh.
It's amazing.
What do you mean?
I almost shoved those goggles in your mouth
and F.
I was doing amazing.
Azura's killing us all.
Azura is doing good.
How do we get over to this one?
F is always a good gamer.
We've all seen it multiple times.
Azura is just nothing fucking new.
I can't fucking do this.
Icy, get away from me.
Don't hit me.
Wait, what?
I did not hit her.
I did not.
What the fuck?
I was so close.
What?
I have to be back all the way over here?
Are you kidding me right now?
Fucking shit.
Please stop.
We'll play the beginner map.
We'll play golf with friends
where we can jump.
Golf with friends?
Enemies.
Damn Royale Golf.
Wow.
All right.
Here we go, folks.
Here you go.
Here's a bunch of nothing.
Here we go.
Go girl.
Wait, I also got monkey spam.
You also got monkey spam?
Yeah.
What the heck?
Chongo, what are you doing, brother?
Don't even say their name.
They love attention.
I wish I had mods.
That'd be great.
Same.
I think everyone's mods are not used to this game.
They're like asleep right now.
Remember.
Yeah, thank you for
remembering Azura.
Thank you for the member.
What was his name again?
We can all celebrate his name.
Azura?
For the member?
Yeah.
I'm now recovering from this.
There's financial ruin because of golf.
Stagfin.
Thank you Stagfin.
Stagfin?
I don't know, I'm just guessing.
Thank you Mr. Siegfried.
I'm sad, I am sad.
Thank you Mr. Sigma.
Sigma nuts.
Actually I was wondering,
would you guys ever go to Saucon with me?
Saucon.
I'm so happy I didn't fall.
I was about to say.
I was like,
I don't want to warn you guys.
I was like, nah, let them fall.
Where's my ball?
At least they don't know about Madder Daddy's.
That's all I'm saying.
That's another one.
What is Madder Daddy's?
Oh, Notha, how about you baby girl?
Madder baby.
Would you rather eat a baby ghoul
or a Madder baby?
It was Madder.
Oh, I know this one.
I know, it was Madder with you.
I know this one.
Did you already go?
Oh, wait.
I'm waiting for you.
I didn't notice.
I was laughing too hard.
Thank you Grim by Vila
for the 10 gifted membership.
Thank you Grim by Vila.
We got a lot of money for the 100 dollars.
Thank you.
It smells slow for me.
Are you okay?
It's not blue.
Why is it white?
Why?
You can't just ask that.
It has blue tails.
Yeah.
Where's the hole?
Is this the X?
No, X is not the hole.
X is not the hole.
X marks us up.
That's not it.
Are they fake holes?
They might be fake holes.
Wait, can I clip through
and see where this leads to?
Why is it a point on the hole?
I'm more surprised.
Are you kidding me?
How did it not fall in?
I don't get that.
How am I supposed to get there?
Don't tell him.
Don't tell her.
She'll figure it out.
You got this, Trani.
You're so close.
Hold on.
No, Trani, it's definitely the one behind you.
I'm in commission, Trani.
Trani, it's the one behind you.
No, it's the one.
It's the one you're right next to right now, Trani.
It's that one, Trani.
Get that one.
Right there.
Trani, go for it.
Trani's here right now.
You're getting suspended.
You're not getting suspended.
I'm not getting suspended.
I'm getting suspended.
I was like first suspension of Vila right now.
Oh, shit, it's moving.
If I got that in whole in one,
I would have literally just sucked my own pee pee.
I'm going to cry.
Don't worry.
I'll do it.
Just scream.
Your microphone control is so good.
Damn.
I fucking can't.
I think I'm going to play.
Can I stop bouncing?
For the love of God?
Alright, there you go.
I need to like aim higher.
Okay, that was far too hard.
I almost got it.
Too much power.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Okay, this one's hard.
I have the power.
I've got the power.
Shit.
Let's go.
What?
I literally just got in.
How did I not get in?
Did you guys see that?
Fucking ball.
Chat, did you see that?
I literally just made it in
and they kicked me back.
Same.
That's okay.
Are you shitting me right now?
And then too hard.
Please stop moving.
Just get in.
Finally.
Oh my God, A.C. is still playing with the hell.
How did you get over there?
$25, thank you.
Thank you.
No, we were going to have time.
Oh, right.
Time's up.
Hey, I came in third.
I got the grease flag.
Grease flag, baby.
Why am I playing?
Why am I going to do with this?
I got a shadow.
Oh my God.
I got witches up.
I didn't get anything fucking beautiful.
I got goggles.
$500.
From who?
What the fuck?
Mercy, why do you leave?
Thank you God.
Thank you Mr. James.
$500.
I need to be invited again.
I'm sorry.
She just got so mad and left.
That's okay.
I rage quit.
I'm so sorry.
You're so real for that though.
We win.
At least you won first place.
Like me.
Yeah.
Surely.
Perhaps you guys don't get the password.
Why what?
Yeah.
Added instead.
Remember to
use
Everyone's cold.
For what?
What the fuck?
You're cold.
That's amazing.
Wait, did somebody do what I did?
What did you do?
Nothing, never mind. Let's not talk about it.
No, no, no.
Oh wait, I know.
Avoid if we...
We never did it.
Never did it.
What took place though?
Our lovely
super bunny
Mandy.
I've been chilling.
Gamers up so hard.
By the way,
guess what I'm drinking?
Blah, blah, blah.
I'm forever drinking lean.
I'm sorry. That sounds bad.
I really like lean. Lean is good.
I wish I had the caffeine one of lean.
Wait, didn't they...
I want lean.
I need to get high.
No, no, no.
It doesn't.
He's wearing a mustache and glasses.
I don't think I got an invite.
You're in the game.
Oh, there we go.
Look, we are playing golf in my home.
We're in the ice hole.
Shit.
Wow, and I'm doing fucking terrible.
Is it more slippery because it's icy?
I think so.
Yes, I mean...
You can go on.
Go on then, Stormy. Go on.
I need to get to going.
Otherwise, I'm going to hit you
and I'm going to laugh at you.
That's the question.
That's why...
You want to slip on me?
You need to slip on these slides.
I'm going to achievement.
Hit the ball 110.
No one special, but actually special to me.
Thank you.
She's special to me.
She's very special to me.
AC has home and family.
What the heck?
Let's fucking go.
Wait, I wish I could zoom.
Why can't I control the camera?
I think you can.
It's the scroll wheel.
Alright.
Azure, your mic's cut and everything.
If I turn around and go back to the hole
that we went to before, does that count?
I'm tweaking.
That's so hot.
I think it would count.
That's 3,500.
3,500?
Let's go.
Thank you for recording.
Thank you.
Oh, my internet died.
There's that moving truck.
Thank you.
Azure will go over the names
after the collab.
I promise she'll do it.
I'll make her do it.
That's very sweet.
A majority of everyone is a thought of this.
There's 100.
Oh, baby.
I'm happy right now.
It's okay.
Her crying is going to make me want to cry.
I just want to hug her.
Oh, my gosh.
You are doing fantastic, sweetie.
You deserve this.
100%.
We're getting you out of that house.
I'm getting you out of that house.
I'm just going to fucking sit.
Don't meet me, Mods.
Don't meet me in a minute.
Go, go, send her some love, guys.
I can't even say it.
I love you all.
Okay, we have advantage now that
Azure fucked up that last one because she's so happy.
Hold on, gamers.
We've got the good ending.
That's right.
Keep supporting Azure so we can win.
She wins everything.
We play real.
Let's go.
I'm trying so hard.
I tried.
Geography.
I didn't hit it hard enough.
I can't see.
Oh, no.
She's tearing up.
She can't see the mask.
She can't see.
I can't see.
It's okay.
We have advantage.
That means we can win.
You can finally lose.
Sorry, my internet is dying.
Oh, no.
Thank you.
For once in my life.
Why am I on top of scrawny?
Yeah, you like that.
Why am I on top of Azure?
What's happening?
Is your ping high?
No, your ping can be high.
My internet is dying right now.
Where's the hole?
I lose.
Watch an A.C.
Bogle's flying and then hearing...
No, I didn't really...
I fucking hit it.
Why does it say I have five strokes?
I don't understand that.
I never...
Hell yeah, hell yeah, hell yeah.
What the hell?
No.
Damn it.
It has a goal.
Hit you.
Can I land in another place?
Oh shit.
My internet is dying.
That lock is scaring me.
Oh my god.
Fuck my nuts.
Why is it so hard?
My legs healed.
I tried so hard.
No, stop.
In the end.
Not you guys, you guys are fine.
Please, Jesus fucking Christ.
I'm gonna kill my mom.
I'm gonna kill my dad.
I'm gonna be like a champion.
I can't do this one.
I did it.
I literally can't do this one.
You can, Emmy.
I believe in you.
Oh, she literally actually can.
I can't do it.
Are the holes over there?
No, my internet.
Oh, thank you.
Whoever hit me, I appreciate that.
It was me with me.
You're welcome.
I can't see.
Surprise.
There you go.
Please don't hit me off.
I will cry.
Oh, thanks.
Appreciate that.
I should just say where I am because people will just hit me.
Get out of my way.
Stop.
I don't have a chance to do anything.
I am not
shouldn't you right now?
I'm stuck on a rock.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Hold R for reset.
Oh, OK.
OK, let's go.
Save.
So is it impromptu?
karaoke?
That was almost a move.
That was a good one.
I got stuck on it.
I need 30 seconds left.
I'm very on.
She made it.
I'm stuck.
I got it.
Oh, my gosh.
Shit.
I'm unable to.
What the fuck is ASMR happening right now?
Wow.
Clearly, I don't have any advantage.
This is some nice music.
Whee.
Oh, no way, I can't do that.
Fuck.
Oh, thank you.
No.
Any time.
Happy to oblige.
Nice job.
Oh, shit.
No.
Are you kidding me right now?
Ah!
Hard, baby.
You were a masochist.
We're getting whacked about, Amy.
We thought you were a masochist.
I was like this.
Sorry, Amy.
I'm sorry.
You just fond in front of me out of nowhere.
Nice job, I see.
Where's the whole at?
OK, she's behind us.
Pure wire halt.
OK, that was a bit too aggressive.
That's fine.
No, that's aggressive.
All right.
Lower that test off to run.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gamer move.
Why can't I hide?
I wish this was a game mechanic.
Fuck this.
Thank you so much for the talk, Sophie.
Minimum power.
Maximum power.
I think you're wrong, Amy.
So true, Bresty.
You're wrong.
No.
What?
My mouse is freaking out as well.
Oh, perfect.
Squeak, squeak.
What?
Squeak, squeak, squeak.
I need to get a new mouse.
My mouse double clicks, and I'm getting extra strokes.
That's useful for some games.
No, I'm stroking.
No, you're not stroking mine.
Whoa.
It is diswanding.
I can't.
I see what Strawny would say.
I just won this wedding.
I can't either.
So you won the wedding?
Sister's wedding?
Who's getting married to Amy?
What's her name?
I'm a good girl.
She's getting married.
Oh my god, fuck you can jump in golf with friends, so I'm disappointed this isn't that and isn't in this game
Okay
I'm familiar with this game. I'm actually not familiar with both the friends should be it's the opposite for me
I'm familiar with golf with friends, but this is my first time playing. Yeah, same
Underdog game
Strap and thank you I hate this
Like
Normally she makes the other screams, so I know it's nice to be on the receiving end of her screams
I'm on X games. Oh, that didn't work. I'm on X games. Oh
That kind of
Oh too hard
Oh
You better get the party started
If you're gonna spawn golf and at least make your hey, I'm in first for the first time. Oh
My god, what was it?
Oh
What the shibbity wait wait I can take this to my advantage
You're gonna put that in my head
The music is so calm considering how chaotic we are
I'm blowing it. I'm blowing my lead
I hate I hate video game and I hate gaming and I hate
Bring anyone and anything alright, I'm innocent
If everyone wants to pick I'll take responsibility for picking this one
I thought this was the main one apparently it's golf it with friends, but I've never played golf it guys
I literally
I originally thought it was golf with friends. I would love to tell the story is a row. Yeah
So Emmy hosts the lobby and we're all joining and is there is like it's just no letting me in
We're like, okay, that's strange. Okay. Well, you know what we've got enough time
We'll go by golf with friends and she's like go for friends. Yeah go for friends cuz we're on golf it right now
She's on the wrong game
Patiently
Where's the hole how do we get in there?
I'll take it
Something and I did nothing, you know what see my ancestors big William Wallace I call upon me
What the fuck are you doing? Come on?
Where we go, I just want to win one round of golf it before we have to pop off
I'm already popping off
Where's the whole
ostero
From
Baste no question mark occupational
We did 650
Can you see that
I'm on the edge of glory right now. You're gone this map. Yeah, I know. Oh, Frostyno.
Frostyno. Frostyno. I don't know how I got Bastardo from Frostyno, to be honest.
That's the hole. You're on a different one. That's the last level.
Hey, don't leave. Don't leave. Don't leave.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Perfect. There's a hole.
A little 1-8-8. Look at it. Look at it. Like going in and out.
What? Excuse me.
Okay, I'm gonna let them all collate ahead. I know I'm just rolling.
I'm not gonna kiss me, but come on.
Let me roll and I hate this. There you go, I see.
The A killing me. I love getting beat up by you.
We are bulls with the bank together. Oh, what the heck? Please don't hit me.
Oh, no! Am I going backwards? We are going backwards on the hill.
We're strong. Oh, there she is.
Oh, there she is.
Strani, you're going the wrong way, sweetheart.
Wait, why is it and I'm getting pushed forward?
It's because it's the ice. It's the ice. Ice, ice, ice, baby.
Oh my god.
I can't wait to take the first spot from Strani because of this one.
I need to possess my Robert the Bruce right now.
I'm gonna teach you a little bit about Scottish history, right?
Big Robert the Bruce Eye. He said English. No, you're not having this land.
And why is he not possessing me right now? Because what's going on?
I have no idea what she's talking about.
I don't watch the stream and you all have to sit in it.
His name is Robert the Bruce, Big Willie Wallace, Big Mary, Queen of Scots.
Oh my god, A.C. Wubbins, we spanked. Oh, I love you, A.C. Wubbins.
I didn't have to.
And we go, shit.
I must confess.
Merce, okay, Merce, you can go first.
There's a Mulan song that goes like, and sisters hear my plea.
Do, do, do, do, do, do. Make a fool of me.
I'll bring honour to Scotland.
She'll bring honour to us all.
Hey, you know what, you know what?
It's so cute.
I wonder what, what, what?
I understand. The Azura goal on our screen right now says
Azura's sus audio roleplay. We couldn't actually put what the content
of that roleplay is on the screen.
Maybe fall. Oh, it's behind us.
Did I get it?
What?
What the fuck?
I was trying to see if I could pop over.
Not bad, not bad.
Aw, dang it.
Let's go golfing. Aw, dang it.
Well, that didn't work.
I love AC's frustration screams.
Cause they're cute. I'm like mine. They're like, you know, like a pterodactyl.
Pterodactyl?
That scream in my microphone doesn't pick it up.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, fuck me, bro.
Okay.
Aw, come on.
Give me, give me. I've got a bone to pick with.
Hold on a minute. Your tweet gave me a heart attack.
Cause it didn't display fully.
So the first sentence is I'm leaving viola and I'm like, aww.
No, no, no.
Not like this.
At least let me hit the three month anniversary before someone goes.
Please.
Sorry, she was having a little stomachache.
It's not over until it's over. You know what I'm saying?
Oh, what the hell?
No, what?
How do they do worse on the second part?
Holy shit.
Holy one.
Son of a...
What did you do?
I'm watching her stream right now. I'm opening up her stream. I want to see.
Stay, stay, stay, stay, stay, stay.
No.
That's fucking amazing.
She beat me. You whore.
You beat me by one point because of that hole in one.
You're American on here, please.
It's alright. I'm also Scottish.
It's also the Scotland. Let's go.
You better be Scottish.
Everyone drink water.
I'm sorry. Water. But I have gamer stuff. Is that okay?
It's not the only water you need. Use code Marcy for 10% off.
Let them know. Use code Marcy for 10% off gamer subs. Let them know.
Use code Zara. Use code Chibi. Use code IC.
Use code Emmy. Use code Stryker.
I'd rather you use the girls' codes than my codes. So use one of their codes instead.
Let's go.
I didn't get a prize. So rude.
No consolation prize, exactly. No. I got third place and I didn't even
get a medal or a prize or even an achievement.
I didn't get anything either.
Participation award.
You get a participation award.
To ground my enemies with...
How did I come in first and then not get anything?
I can be sushi.
I want to be your whole in one.
I want to be your whore in one.
Thank you.
This is a four.
I don't know why.
I like being spanked.
Give me a moment. I need to rethink that one.
Honestly, I need to recalibrate the joke.
Give me a second.
That's all I need. I just need a moment.
Zara with the whole in one.
It's all about time and all.
Oh, come on.
Thank you.
I'm on a lily pad.
Not too hard, but hard enough to make you through.
Not too hard, but hard enough to make you come.
Give me that par.
My enemies now in my way.
I see a struggle.
Can I get a sanity check on our polar bear?
I would like a sanity check on our polar bear.
Thank you so much for 100 dollars.
Thank you.
What was the name?
Are we all like to say that?
Are we going to?
No.
What about grooming?
Brushing your hair.
Plenty of grooming to go around.
I have five birdies.
Is your make on or am I getting nervous that you're deadly silent?
Because you're about to go feral.
Silence from mercy is scary.
From AC's worst because she's feral polar bear.
She's learning how to begin civilization again.
I'm getting nervous. I'm getting shaky.
Can you hear me?
I was talking. I was talking.
I was talking.
What the fuck?
I was literally still raging.
It was awfully quiet without your raging.
It's time to rage some more.
Exactly. Where am I?
Can I?
What the heck is this?
This is going to be a headache and a hassle.
Unless.
No.
What the fuck?
Was the picture on Twitter or keyboard broken?
I don't know.
This is so rude.
Why did you go that way?
It's the wrong way.
Fuck I'm fucking stupid.
It's like me. I hate video games.
I hate golf.
You're becoming a hater.
Maybe I always was.
I was the hater.
I was not too good.
I see land in the middle.
Upwards.
Upwards and then you land in the middle of that bridge.
In the middle of this bridge.
Try aiming for the wall.
Upwards.
Just a little.
Oh no.
You're going to run out of time.
Baby.
Sorry.
I almost got a hole in one.
I did a rimshot.
You know what I'm saying?
You were saying?
Thank you very much.
Sorry, the aim at the end of that was brother.
Here I am.
Nice.
Here we go.
Almost.
I'm looking back.
She's dying.
5 members.
That was pretty close.
Thank god.
I almost got a hole in one on that one.
I hate video games and I hate golf.
Tiger Woods.
Does anyone know any names of any other golfers?
I don't watch golf.
OJ Simpson.
Did you say OJ Simpson?
He's a football player that murdered his wife.
That's what he is.
My apologies.
I don't know American things.
I tried my best.
You tried.
I know fictional golfers.
Fictional golfers?
There's no end on fictional golfers.
In the anime and video games.
That makes sense.
I'm getting edge by a hill.
Baby.
No triple.
Baby a double.
Sheepie's gone over.
I'm locked in.
I'm 100.
Thank you for the 5 hundo.
I'm coming back to the start.
You put me back to the start.
You do that on your table.
I'm so close.
I literally rolled on her POV.
What?
You're a race.
I can't believe it.
I was too soft.
You gotta be dumb.
I can't believe it.
You sprinkled salt on your balls.
Did you know that if you dip your balls in soy sauce you can taste it?
You can probably do that right now.
I had my viewers do it.
They said it wasn't true.
You're supposed to tea.
It was pretty nice.
Somebody dipped it in syrup too.
That's when you know he's Canadian.
Popped that stuff in maple syrup.
I don't know what the Canadian theme song is.
That's not what they're called.
Canada.
I love it.
You have a video of the person dipping their toes in the peanut butter.
Someone was licking it off.
If one of you guys dipped your toes in peanut butter
don't mind me.
I love peanut butter.
for you. I love peanut butter.
smooth peanut butter personally.
I don't like peanut butter.
Wow.
Can you eat it or is it bad?
It's like real peanuts.
If it's made out of like a bunch of other stuff, I can't eat it.
Yeah, there's peanut butter that's like 100% just peanut.
You're fucking shitting me right now.
That's the only one I can eat.
You can eat me.
Strawny's on my arse.
I'm coming.
I need to keep.
It's all good.
Oh, sorry.
I couldn't hear.
What did you say?
I didn't hear it.
They're all talking about peanut butter.
Someone said all of a sudden I'm a dog.
I see.
What the fuck?
Someone hit you.
I didn't hear it.
I'm going to be stuck here all fucking day.
Go ahead.
Damn, she's doing that rim job.
We love hearts coming off you.
Strawny is straddling me right now.
We're on the same number.
What does she get distracted by?
Slime.
Slime girl.
I hate slime girls.
I'm so angry about slime girls.
Slime girls.
I want to fuck them.
Here, you're going to have to help me out.
Distraction.
Let the squish win.
I'm a threat. What is happening?
Oh, what is happening?
Don't they're getting corraled like animals.
Don't you see the game has us pitched against each other.
But through the power of friendship and love, we'll make it.
In the words of Icy, that's so true, Bresty.
She choked, she choked, folks.
She fucking choked.
She choked that chicken.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to fart.
I'm angry.
Oh, come on.
Can't be too hard.
Go first.
Thank you.
You knocked me off the mat twice to restart me.
That's at least a bit of payback.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Keep choking, she's eating.
Oh, no.
Oh, dear, she be am I getting under your skin hen?
Oh, dear.
Remember that time the men put the tea in the harbor?
Aye, that's right.
I don't remember.
Even though I'm full, I don't remember.
Oh, it's there.
That is there.
That's right.
That is historically accurate.
That's what's bothering me.
I was watching it.
Is the Americans revolted against the taxes against you?
Aye, that's right.
God damn it.
It's working.
Right.
Someone else give me American history.
Come on.
Quick.
Come on, hold.
She's like, I was there.
I was there.
Everyone should just start speaking in their accent,
their actual accent.
I don't think anyone would understand me if I started
lifting it on.
It is my accent.
I don't think anybody wants to hear my New England accent.
Go for it, go for it, go for it.
Go for it.
Oh.
No, I'm too shy.
New personal.
Oh, that's so cute.
Their actual accents.
This is my accent.
Well, I'm literally taking in.
So cute.
I'm trying.
That was pretty cute, Emmy.
I won't lie to you.
That was really cute.
It's like my accent.
Oh.
Oh, your homework.
Why you no doctor?
Oh, my God.
Mercy.
She's allowed to do it.
Hold on.
She's allowed to do it before anyone starts getting weird.
You can do it.
She's a liar.
I don't know how to do it.
Canceling Mercy.
Fuck.
Canceling her.
Drops.
Hello, welcome in.
Hello.
I don't lie.
It was an ASMR idea too.
Well, not really ASMR because it was like really aggressive
and it would be a lot of yelling.
Yeah.
Anybody want anything from Donk's kid?
Yeah, you fucking stupid.
From what?
What?
That was not my bar before anyone starts accusing.
That was not me for once.
That was my bar.
That was Amy's burp?
That was a really good burp.
That was a very good burp.
Oh, fuck.
This is hard.
Oh, thank you for lighting me up though.
I see.
Hold on.
Let me go.
Give me a second.
Oh, my God.
No.
I'm assuming.
How are we saying that?
I said, let me go.
How the fuck?
Who just spanked me?
Oh, no.
Should I go back again?
2D suspension.
And we're going to make up a story about how you don't feel
well, 2D suspension right now.
Azura, do not move, Azura.
Sheebie.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting my turn.
Everybody's chaotic right now.
Fucking go.
Azura.
Azura, go.
Fuck it.
Oh, my God.
Give me time.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, no, wait.
You just got knocked in.
What?
You just went in for me and then you jumped out.
Strongly.
The ping is the ping.
Oh, my God.
Did it keep hitting me?
It's in your neck.
I'm winning.
I'm still winning.
There's a chance.
So you're saying there's the chance.
So you're saying there's a chance.
I'm going to lose.
You got this, Amy.
Just time me out already.
You killed me.
Thank you.
Thank you, binary.
Call fit.
The game is pain personified.
It is.
How am I?
OK.
How are we supposed to get there?
I'm so sorry.
Whoever went in the water.
But I heard the SFX so clearly.
It was like, it was so high quality.
Strongly, you better go.
I'm on a ramy in the boat.
I have, I have, but I keep moving.
Someone hit me and I keep moving.
I know I know.
I need to get away.
I'm in.
No, I was so close.
Fuck.
Shit, albatross.
I'm in.
I can't.
Oh, that's a great song.
Pop, pop, pop.
Real gamer blames the pangs.
Exactly.
My pain is astronomical.
This is going to be so fucking hard.
Displead.
I hate this.
If I hit someone in there, I'm gonna be so pissed.
The war physics in this game, I have to compliment it when we use it on the war.
Someone named CPS just tipped me in talking about how I killed my Tamagotchi.
Oh no!
He hasn't forgiven you for your crimes against your Tamagotchi.
I've killed many a Tamagotchi.
I might choke out for this.
Oh man.
Oh shit.
Yes!
So much for the $500!
Wow!
Holy shit.
From who?
Let's fucking go.
From Garfunkel.
Garfunkel!
Thank you Mr. G.
More like bank funkel.
More like bang funkel.
I don't fucking know.
First places we meet up with you.
What's the art?
Wait just trying to get in.
Oh I'm fucked.
Yeah, Sonny got it.
Check out the scoreboard.
Press shift and see how many it took me to do.
We're gonna find out what happened to me.
Yeah.
Are you fucking shitting me right now?
I've made my ancestors proud.
I can mess up everything after that.
I got a white top hat.
Costa Rica flag.
I unlocked a literal Joby.
I unlocked a literal door because I'm stupid I was also too excited a maybe I don't know
I miss so many I miss so many
Close your eyes
Very
I'm really feeling it. Are you feeling it now mr. Mercy? Should I do?
Should I do should I do hard mode? Yeah, do it. Yes
And then we'll end on this one because we've almost
If I think one more game is gonna take us like 30 minutes and then Azura can get on with her business
Grim by Vila I get strengths again with the
You're gonna kill Icy with hard mode
Lagging
I can't wait. I'm sorry. I forgot to hit ready. I was waiting for you. These carrots
Oh
Fucking carrots, we're on the farm reef lens
Sorry Pete have a milk and farm. Please excuse me
This is a weird J temple
There's turnips on the floor. What's with the random bar at the bottom?
No, I radishes
How do you get on the thingie strontie strontie, don't do it baby strontie. I'm not
We are I think we're touch it. Oh, no, we're not touching or we're very close to touching tips
Oh my gosh, am I
This is anyone's when because of how awkward this map is this is literally anyone's win. It's my game
Why do I keep on getting back one of y'all
Okay, we're in yes, yes. Yes. Yes, you know what this is the last game I choose violence
Oh
Why am I in such a bad spot a bitch?
Amy Amy move first, okay?
I'm still at the fucking beginning
Thank you
Back in the fucking building
I'm going I'm going I'm going for you. I'm there's like a pat you got four seconds. Three seconds. It's fine
I'm still moving can I it doesn't matter
We're supposed to go to that island all the way over there. I'm all the war you can skim across it like oh
Fuck oh, but you're not supposed to go inside the water. Oops
Okay, you can't land in the water
Why is it doing this you have an enemy? It's me. I've chosen violence. I will destroy all of you
Everyone stay away from she be where we're gonna be
Why am I in water but not that was weird?
Why oh
I'm safe. I'm safe and just kidding. I see decided
My oh shit
Wait, I have an idea
Wait, I'm actually really close. I'm really close
I
Thank you so much for the $50
I bounced out fuck me
Easy hole in one watch this watch this easy hole in one easy easy easy easy see that
I
Through the end so whoever second place can win have it. Oh, no, no, no, I'm gonna I'm gonna kick you out
That's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna fire in your eyelashes. Don't give me pink. I I don't need that
Sure, you have the cleanest arsehole in all the land
I'm
You got ass up and fart strongy, so you'll probably give me pink
You far with that
Suspension right I'm making up. I'm making up the lie right now. And she be
Oh
Unfortunately, she's offline for 40 hours, don't worry. I'm putting up the white page and what takes I'm like
Sorry for what I must do. Oh, you're lucky you escape. We are so sorry to report that our precious talent
Sorry
Oh, hey, mercy, what's up?
You're not through in the game you're just kissing with your walls
You're just touching balls
Like your womb walls
Cuz I'm about to insert myself
Oh
My love tabs
This looks fun actually, I kind of I kind of
Almost took the advantage there
What about me to me what I am?
What I just hit an invisible wall
Oh my god, those are like those soba noodles in Japan where you the noodles
That's why I said it looks fun
And we just turned Scott always fell out a door when you guys
accent I just love it. I'm like
Are you fucking?
I actually did that time I didn't go after you
right well
Can work can wait can actually work. That's it. I've had enough
The easiest I'll give you a sentence and you'll have to mimic it. Okay, okay
You see you're gonna come to my house. You would say my bit. So what the sentence is
I can I can't he wait for you to come to my bed
For you to come to my bed
for you to come to my bit
Literally and then
Okay
Come to be how much money to have you motivate me to finish cleaning my room. So what?
Free for you
And yours
Everyone's got to go Xima Sue. Oh, no
Oh, oh, yeah, I told goes I mass
Mochi-mochi
I can't believe you've done this
Fucking go from here from here
Accelerate
Excel road. Thank you for you're getting a golf club actual road. I think that's
Pregnant
No, no, I need to go to the right. Literally, it's too dangerous
Oops, Daisy, where the fuck is the hole?
I can't go straight I can only go gay
Give us a second
Just the name or I did it. Oh, here's another phrase for you
I'm about to set the fucking
Stevie's edging I'm edging why do I keep edging? I'm not
The one
If you know why are you guys saying penalized penalize
Thank you. Oh, shit
I'm falling into the ether. Oh my god, this bridge is like Matt. Oh, it keeps me going
It's a conveyor belt
Yeah, like it takes you all the way across make sure you aim for the middle
I kid you not aim for the middle or it's gonna keep your trajectory in Tara Sante
Oh, I see I see time to ruin it
You
I
Share that peepee with the rest of us
Do you have enough to share with the class
I never learned to pronounce their names, so I named them that's cute
I don't know how I actually managed to just got renamed by a zero. I see I'm gonna start calling you everybody different names now
Yeah, that's me. There we go. Perfect flawless imagine she gets in oh god damn it
What is their carrots?
Well, you know
Oh
Oh my god, we're getting carried by the river. This is so cute
Yeah
Nice
I'm so sorry if I hit someone
That's me. I hit the birthday girl. Look a little bit violent. Be mindful of the current
I'm not hitting it hard enough. I'm too scared
I'm on I'm on the river lazy liver lazy
Okay, we made it lazy live or fuck
Morel it
Fuck my life. I knew what you're gonna. Stroni. I can read your mind from here
Shebe's in my head
No, I'm falling
No, ain't no way how did I do that?
Why does it the current take you around the whole I don't
Guess who's back who's dying
Mercy's dying
I'm
I'm gonna kill myself in minecraft
Yeah, hold on a minute. That's why you got hired
What on earth is the context of that?
It made me or may not
have been chosen
For her say a man of words that she used against someone
That was rather inappropriate for most agencies
But you know, you know what we do a little bit
What the fuck is up kyle
Step the fuck up kyle
And I never oh no
Oh
Where am I?
I'm about to murder
Wait, how are we supposed to get past the lantern? You gotta jump it. You got a xk games
I made it. Oh, this is far away. I didn't mean to hit
I
Shit no, please
This is not what I wanted
All right, is that there's make fixer
Fixing her
Right now I'm gonna fart on it
I'm sorry
Oh my god, you think you use this shit?
Keep it a stack there we go
Don't
Oh my
Azur ran out of strokes
Mercy ran out of time
Last play
Just losing it
Um, excuse me your excuse
Have I gone the wrong way where the no, I think you're in the right spot
Hey
Are we supposed to hit that really hard? I think oh come on. Are we supposed to hit the that
Where'd my thing go? I'll tell you
Oh
Where am I and how am I supposed to get there?
Uh, I just fell off the face of the earth
This I'm still falling
Okay, but where's the where's the hole?
I said the the the fucking the the blue jet jet the the grill. I don't know
Like the the golden paw of blue sapphire like in grail
Like do you see them?
Oh my gosh
Yeah
Oh, it's the pond. Okay. Oh, it is the pond cauldron thing. That's weird
Oh my god
It's the cauldron looking thing the cauldron that's burner. Yeah, I'm sure it has like an actual name
But I'd have no idea what to call it
It's an actually know what the function of this
Time
Wait to go out top of gachi is ugly again. I'm not blessed place. Who would have thought
I'm
I appreciate you being here. You need to pick a game that you're good at you can like
It's so over. I don't know if we told you when we first met we played
um
That party game
What is it called checkbox? Yeah, I played jack box
Emperor icicle was lost again and I and I felt so bad. I was like, no
Ow more PTSD from being last place
And it wasn't fair because the questions were like english questions and they're really awkward like words that it's not everyday vocabulary
So it was like, what is the plural of like this word?
What is a baby of this animal called and it was like
This is one fair on ac English isn't your first language
It's okay. I just have low IQ with spine. No
It makes you incorrect
You're not dumb for it. You're not dumb for it. That's incorrect. Jen is not denying it
Thank you. Thank you
Thank you, mr. Ray kuma. I'm not a shit
any recoumers
Any ray kumas in here?
Oh my god, you really are a fucking higher in the delivery chalk. What the fuck? Oh my god, the next girl is the peeler allegation. Oh, fuck
Wait, what's the peeler allegation?
Or may not have peed on
Microphone Azura hasn't and I'm next after her. I said if Azura finishes it, I have to I will finish it
Wait, I have to look at her because we've all we peed
We pulled lemonade into the toilet. I don't know. Yeah, yeah, lemonade wink. We made lemonade. Yeah, yes
I don't mean I don't know
I need to look at Azura's channel
I've done literally
I've done worse things on my own channel
Okay, why does it look like there's shit everywhere, but they're wrong
It's the wrong
We need m&a need shibi need and mersey need so Azura need is next and then strawney strawney need just sounds like a grenade to me
strawney need
I'm just slew. Yeah, don't mind me
cheeky willy peat over here
You gotta hit the middle of the center. You gotta
I literally cannot get on this
I can't seem to feign to the common
Is everyone struggling to get on this
Oh
It's just you
Tabernac there. I said it
I hate
What
I'm punishing
Whenever I mean merseymus behave I punish them with french, but not just any kind of french scottish accent
I know
I'm stupid
I would like a peeler allegation
Oh my internet's going again
Not my internet
I heard her voice
Okay, let me
You sound like a character from in any sims game well when I do a Scottish accent on a different language
Over for me
What are we saying is this is this too much?
Why are you going to do this?
Well, if you get stuck you're supposed to hold R. Yeah. Yeah
Stop the entire time. We're stuck. We're stuck. Please
Please
Okay
Please for the love of god
I want to go this way just because
Uh, you can't go that way
You cannot go that way
You'd be sent to the asylum after this fucking
I like how mercy is friggin bats
AC had a short that came out and it was her missing a word and I got so many views
No, my internet, please dumb ac
My internet. Oh, no
The best I've done
Oh my internet
It's not asylum. It's asylum
Asylum
Yes, asylum
It was such it did so well I was like fuck you
I keep messing up your English
Oh, right don't do it too hard don't do it too hard up that
Too late
Oh, and I did it too gentle. You know the the designs are quite nice here
Nobody can hear me because my internet died again
Oh
I'm I'm dying slowly, but it's fine game. I'm so I'm still in game. My internet just keeps cutting out
The game is the internet is like, I know what's important here. Make sure she can continue playing the game
Literally, what the fuck
Okay, there are bridges to go down so you don't need to whack too hard to get to the bomb
I like to whack hard though. Get out of my way
Hey
What the hell it looks like
It's like emmy had picked up strontis ball
On my screen from the live they're taking me away. They're taking me away because I've had enough of me being in game
It's what I'm kidding. I love you. I love you all even though I hate the golf
It's okay. I will do the same exact reaction
in golf
Let's go I see
Hey
We did it we did it. Okay, so what's this one? Oh, we gotta go up. Yeah, you go go high
Thank you. Oh, I made it. No, I didn't fuck my life
Oh
Oh my god
Okay, no, this is
You tapped for this the tip. Oh, I don't know. That's gonna use the god's way. Don't mind if I do don't mind if I do
Hey, let's let's get on the cam. Let's go on the cam. I don't see what's happening
Let's get on the cam. What are we five nights at Freddy's characters?
I'm getting the action replays
Oh my fuck keep on that way is there a you take like a right angle, bro
Uh-huh brother brother want to commit sudoku and cry
It's it's seppuku
And she knows that that's the that's the meme. That's the meme
I'm gonna commit sudoku
Sudoku is a is a number game
Yeah, I know. Yes. Yes. It's my favorite game. I like the game. I'm really good at it. I'm bad at sudoku
I'm great at sudoku though
What whoa
10 seconds just kidding doesn't matter. I stroked out
Did I sneeze?
Oh, could you oh well it bring a lot of publicity though
Uh, you know what just for you strawney
No, I'm teasing before anyone takes that seriously relax
For the views for the views
No, that's terrible. How do I do it for the vine? I am doing it for the vine
I'm gonna do it do it for the vine
You can't stop the gong. That's rude
You can bring the zone
Oh that way
We can't hit the gong. That's so rude
Fuckin house. Oh, no make me do it. Oh, right. No, it's fine. Oh my god. I thought I didn't do it hard
You go in that was amazing. I just saw that strawney. I'm so sorry. I'm stuck dammit. I missed you're not sorry my pink
My pink better than yours. Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty accurate. What is my ping at right now?
Does this say
I never did that was a great trick shot. Oh my god, it's sakura kawaii ne sakura
I think I think my favorite is strawney just speaking really
Really really bad japanese
I think I used to be able to see well actually right this is really terrible lord
I can only see sentences from hentai so I can see
All that feels good in japanese and like
Yeah, we need we need a we need a taste it's like taste test come on
What the fuck is that it's me
That is like and like does it feel good is like
I
No
Wait, listen, listen, I just had like a terrible thing pop in my head. Oh should I say
Say it here. I was like
Damn imagine
off collab taste
test stream where I just taste
Everyone's much
I taste sweet
Oh my god
I've been a great stream
I'm speechless. I can know because I didn't know she was gonna say that
I'm done for anything but
What the fuck right everyone I'll be buying everyone yogurt and hydrating for no particular reasons
Well mercy sweet I want to taste
Yeah
Oh sweet
Sweet sadistic surprise
I
How did you guys set up the stairs the stairs take you up? Yeah, but how I can't
They hate him patrolling they try to catch me riding
Oh
Can I like just fall down into this one
Where do we go
Okay, I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. That's a hell
It's on the floor
That's the old hole into
Is it we're split?
That yes the vintine. We're on for eight. I can't even find it. So I'm looking where are they? I don't know where to go
Oh, I can't see it. It's down
No, that's not actually are you sure it's on the ceiling. It's on the ceiling on the ceiling
Oh
Oh it is
You don't have to tell me twice
It's stupid. Why can't I just go all the way down here? I can't see anything though
Just eat it. I could do you know just bullshit. The hole is literally down there
No, it's on the ceiling. That's the old one. That's the old one. It's all
Fucking stupid never mind. Um, I really thought I found out like an amazing way
What I already tried that way
Gravity changes if you look around gravity changes when you go up so
I don't know how to get up there. I'm sorry
I'm on the wall. I'm on the wall, but I don't know how to get up. Do you see where shabby is?
You need to go on that side and then eat yourself. What's up?
Eating
What the fuck where am I?
Uh
No, I wanted to do it. It looks fun. I wanted to finish
I was so close
Oh
I got a plunger
You got another shit
Oh, I got the plunger. You got the shit. So I I got a pink hat
Who's got the heart
Country boy, I love you
Right, I am going to say a grand spanking. Thank you for everyone for showing up for azir's
Donathan and we got to have real-life time together
I'm happy to say that no, there will not be a white text in black font coming out anytime. I'm getting I'm getting terminated guys
Yeah
I'm gonna have someone skin both of shabby. Uh, just warning, you know, um
I just come back killed next street with a different voice
I mean, I think nothing's different really. What are you talking about?
Yeah, not a man
Hey, what is the agendination is myself and the other girlies are going to all redirect into azir's donathan
You will all be forced to sit and watch it
your azura has
So many plans into today's strum. So please do even if you want to lurk in the shadows
You're more than welcome to
Wait, where the fuck am I on the main menu close to the studio like a dumb
What the actual fuck
We all get redirected to azirah and you're gonna kiss her
And there are no redirected
Yes, there are some girls that are doing streams after their streams. Anyway, there's going straight back into azir. So please don't worry. Please don't worry
Okay, thank you so so much everyone. I'm gonna jump her voice chat and wrap up my stream real quick
Okay, but thank you so much for playing. It was a hit in a hauler. I had a lot of fun
And then there was us
Raina's in my arms and she's eating my hair. Raina, please stop eating my hair
She's eating my hair and trying to groom me. Hi. I'm sorry for the laggy stream and my internet's going
I hope that it rectifies it. Raina stop eating my hair. I hope that it rectifies itself with a
That's right not eating my hair noises by the way
um
It was super fun and uh, I had a lot of
I had a really great time. I apologize my internet's crapping out
Uh, I hope it goes back to normal by the time
I do wedding witch. Oh, I have like really bad allergies
My nose is stuffy. So if you hear me like pulling my nose and sneezing, that's why um
No, Raina has been actually with me the majority of the collab is
I was gonna blame her for me missing my shot at one point, but I didn't
um
But yeah, I'll see you a problem more than like you'll see you guys later. I'm gonna record some stuff
Take a nap. I'm tired. I need that. I'll have some dinner dinner. It's the afternoon. I'll have some lunch
And then um, I'll see you guys a little bit later
Um, but yeah, go say hi to Azura. Please spend time with her wish her happy birthday
And yeah, I'm gonna go. I'm gonna go nappy nap. Oh
Okay, bye, Raina. Bye. Bye everybody. See you later later. Yeah, I got
those hole in ones, bro
those hole in ones anyways
me
Where's my ending screen? Okay, there it is
Oh, my nose is stuffy, but I can still smell how stinky you are
Uh
Ignore the lovin's thing. What the fuck is that?
Do I have to be there? Why is that there?
Oh my god, this mod is gonna be limited to hell
I
Swear to god I was not using that it was left over from house of blue streams. I was messing around with settings
um for like
Recording shorts on obs and I copied over
Some stuff and it looks I don't know why it was there
Oh my god
Why why would I do that out of hold on hold on?
Hold hold hold. Why would I do I'm gonna
Out of all of the streams to do that on on youtube, why would I do it for a club?
No
Oh
My god, I'm going I'm just I'm simply going to disappear now